we have a voicemail number its 2192
david p let's take a listen to this
voicemail that came in hey David I love
patriot mail and I love the fact that
use hate Rhea 40 to make it into a good
thing right but I was just curious who
does the voice for hey tree mail because
it's absolutely hilarious and I can't
tell if it's just and ends there and it
ends there okay well he got cut up um it
is nobody that I can tell you the
agreement is because he is a serious uh
voiceover narration guy he is worried
about the impression that some of his
clients might get if they hear him
voicing things like today's hatred mail
is n turf obika and uh the n-word and
Jews and all that type of stuff so we've
agreed the deal is he'll do the hatred
males for us but I'm not allowed to say
who it is we have a fantastic bonus show
for you today we will talk about flag
protests at Hampshire College Kellogg's
pulling ads from Breitbart and much more
david pakman.com slash membership that's
how you sign up